tasty bits
hello
foreign good afternoon everyone
this week is tiwiki oh tirio Maori or
Maori language week
so for this council meeting we will be
doing uh I'll be opening with the
karakia and closing with the karakia and
then we'll go back to our regularly
scheduled program next meeting
I do have vote in karakia in front of
staff and councilors if you feel like it
feel free to join me at the end with a
tihei mode order
a
TI atakuda here till here hooker here
foreign
welcome everyone I hope you have enjoyed
your short and sweet break but it's good
to see everyone background the council
table
do we have any apologies
I have one from uh councilor Richard
mcphail
do we have any further apologies
could I please have a movie that we
accept the apology from Rich mcphail uh
councilor Stringer and a seconder
councilor guard iron or the favorite
place AI
and against
motion is carried do we have any
conflicts of interest
there appear to be none
onto the confirmation of minutes I'm
gonna try and speed through these
because there's quite a few of them so
please just um stop me if I'm going too
fast
uh first up we have the confirmation of
the minutes of the ordinary meeting held
on the
Thursday oh sorry Tuesday the 11th of
July 2023
are there any questions or changes
requested
does not look like it could have a move
that those are true and correct
councilor MacDonald and a seconder
uh councilor McKenzie all those in favor
please say aye
and against motion is carried onto the
ordinary meeting held on Tuesday the
25th of July 2023
did we have any questions or changes
appears to be none could I please have a
mover they that is a trend correct
record uh Council Dixon seconded by
councilor Phillips
I will put the emotional as in favor
please say aye
and against motion is carried
the extraordinary meeting on Friday the
18th of August 2023
questions or comments
could I have a move that these are true
and correct
uh councilor Fraser in a seconder
uh councilor Reed
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
the motion is carried
audit and risk committee held on Tuesday
the 18th of July 2023
questions or comments
could over mover from that meeting that
the return correct record Council
mcphail seconded by
councilor McDonald
[Music]
all those in favor please say aye
against promotion is carried
policy and Regulatory committee meeting
held on Tuesday the 8th of August
questions comments or concerns
canopies have a mover from that meeting
that they're true and correct councilor
Texan seeking advice counselor Reed
all those in favor please say aye
and against
carried
and that's all of them
before we move on I um this is the first
meeting for councilor Fraser so welcome
good to see you around the table
um with the the voting privileges so
good to see you there
uh urgent or late business did we have
any
there appears to be none
uh update letter from the Department of
internal affairs now
well I organized myself was there any
counselor who would like to speak to
this letter
you know it looks like we're all okay
the leader is pretty self-explanatory in
my opinion I have lost it seems the
emotions that I like to accompany with
this um but the the review itself uh
still sits lays on the table
so I just want to bring it off the table
um and check if anyone would like to go
ahead with the confirming I believe it
was the terms of reference the
unbudgeted expenditure and or the
appointment of Linda Clark for the
process
if there are no movers for those motions
motions will let
and we'll move on I will look for a
mover that this letter is received and
noted
uh Council Stringer seconded by
councilor Phillips
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
item number six the independent review
of the gore multi-ports Chiller and air
handler system
do we have Martin with us oh there we
are welcome Martin uh would you like to
add anything to this report
section
so yeah so this has been an issue that
has been ongoing since 2003 when the
facility opened and really just opening
up the opportunity to have another look
and make sure we do have the best system
possible and getting the most out of it
uh willing to answer any questions if
you have any
thank you Martin councilors do we have
any questions for Martin Council
McKenzie
Martin I see that the system has been
modified at times
from what it was originally who did that
modification to it
uh yeah there was a modification to try
and maintain more heat and that was done
in conjunction I cannot confirm actually
what firm did the work oh yeah um but it
was in conjunction with um
the engineers that did the original
drawings and plans okay no that's all
thank you
thinking counselor councilor Fraser
Martin
um you said it's been having issues
since 2003 yeah that's was that just
ongoing update was that or that major
failures they're having since at that
time
the the main issue we've had is that
it's never been able to maintain
temperature or the warmth temperature
within the ice rink that has been there
since day one we're still trying to get
it up to that temperature we struggle
with that and I guess this review would
really help point out where there are
deficiencies and where we can have
improvements made on that system and
that airflow and that circulation but
also the efficiency of the system as a
whole because it does run in conjunction
with both the ice rink and the pool as
well
so it's an overall review of the entire
system
thank you Martin
any further questions from councilors
uh councilor Dixon
thank you Mr
and the air handler system are both
facilities of the Gould District Council
so will I support South and be involved
in any part of this
review or do they have any say in this
I'm I'm just con wondering about that
uh yet so what we're looking for is an
independent review where someone will
come in overview the whole system and if
they have questions they will go to the
parties that they need that information
from just to probably clarify the air
handler unit itself for the ice rink is
their ownership and and for their them
to maintain whereas the chiller system
itself is all maintained under Council
cancel read
thank you
I was going to ask that we will have
terms of reference for the review
yes Steven
just for clarification there Martin uh
is there a
maybe not terms of references per se but
some guidelines that you went out with
with the quote is that correct
yes that's correct um so what we did was
with the experts we've had involved in
maintenance and previous knowledge they
have formulated a list of questions
which is really going through seeing how
the system operates how it was designed
and really
chicken the nuts and bolts of the the
entire system so that is what we went
out to Tender for to get The Three
Tenors we've received
thank you very much any further
questions
counselor Reed
if this goes above the ten thousand
dollars that councils approved will Ice
Sports Southland be asked to provide
something to help with that budget
uh not at this stage at this stage we're
looking to fund that and the 10 000 that
we've requested is actually
should have room for from what we've
been given that should have room for
movement
councilor guard on did you slip cushion
um the review we'll just look at the
mechanics of it not the overall
Financial package or and how how the
funding is done on both sides
uh yeah so this is totally a review on
the system to see where they can where
the improvements can be made the next
stage from here would to be to sit down
with the likes of isports and ourselves
to see one where those responsibilities
lie as to who has responsibility for
what area of improvement and then that
would have to then
be put into at the long-term budget so
the reason we're looking at it now is
because we're in that ltp stage so we
can look at putting that in and moving
forward
any further questions
I will uh Rex you wanted to comment
I think it's important for the council
to
um
understand that this is a technical
piece of work that's quite specific to
the plant
and the equipment that Martin has the
responsibility to manage as the overall
facility manager he is inherited
a
some the plant and Equipment over time
that was not necessarily and I correctly
hear from wrong but was not necessarily
designed specifically for what it's been
asked to do
um
but we are working with them and have
worked with that for a number of years
and now are wanting to utilize this
independent review
um to a understand that and be identify
areas for improvement that as Martin has
said from a plant and Equipment
perspective if there's anything
significant that comes out of it this
won't be the last time that the council
hears about what that investment might
be required to invest insuring to ensure
that we're able to satisfy the
recommendations from this particular
technical review what I would suggest
with that also is that there is an
opportunity to sit alongside or invite
iceport Southland to participate in the
next phases of this project depending on
what the independent review comes up
with
um this afternoon I have thankfully been
able to find an actual existing
agreement that exists between the
council and I support Southlands around
a service level agreement which will
assist us in going quite a way to
provide if we require a terms of
reference for a working group to be
established at a governance level
between the council and I support
Southlands committee
so I think that there is an opportunity
and we should we should embrace that
opportunity going forward to
um depending on what the independent
review comes out from a plant and
Equipment perspective but see this also
is an opportunity to build that
relationship with our Sports Southland
and review this agreement which I have
in my hand which was signed on the 3rd
of the 2nd of November 2020 so it's
currently in existence we just need to
review that and if you want to have a
governance working group or a governance
reference group to to assist in those
relationship relational matters between
the council and the I support South and
executive committee then that's
something I think that would be a
worthwhile
uh outcome once we receive or once we
find the independent review
findings for the technical piece of
plant and equipment so I think we
differentiate and make sure we
understand hey this is a technical piece
of work to do with planning equipment
but there will be another piece of work
that needs to come in if you want to
resolve along those lines today for for
something like that then we have an
opportunity to establish or to review
their current levels of service I think
it's a service level agreement and
rebuild that relationship at a
governance level with High Sports health
thank you Rex um some good good
suggestions on there and building on
Martin's Point
um I'm going to keep those two issues
separate
um and just focus on the unbudgeted
expenditure for the moment and we will
Circle back to the potential working
group
do we have any further discussion on the
unbudgeted expenditure
councilor McDonnell you want to move it
I want to move move the recommendations
do I have a seconder
uh councilor Fraser
any further debate
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried now
between Ricks and Martin there was a
suggestion of uh potentially forming a
working group is there interest from
councilors in doing that in conjunction
with iceport Southland
I'm seeing sing nodding around the table
uh council oveld do you have a comment I
I think given the ongoing issues and
what could well come out of this review
and given there's also a new committee
for I support Southland that it would be
extremely beneficial for both them and
us to have a working group moving
forward but that working group must have
very clearly defined parameters of what
it's looking at
thank you councilor
um and to that effect I wrote down a
potential recommendation that the
council former working group and that
staff create terms of reference in
conjunction with I support Southland for
approval will also give us a chance to
have a think about who would like to be
on that working group to be accepted at
the next meeting does that sound like a
fair recommendation
can I have a mover for that Council
mixer now and a seconder councilor Havel
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
thank you councilors
appointments to council committees in
other organizations
did the GM of community lifestyle
Services have any further comment on
this report
uh did Council Havel have any further
additions to this report
take it as read
fantastic
did counselors have any questions about
this report
no I just had uh a couple of points the
first was just around the chief
Executives appraisal committee
um and where the councilors felt um
that it was okay if I rejoined that
committee
um with the the departure of um the
chief executive
currency executive is there any issues
with that
seems to be none
so I will add that adjustment to the
recommendation and just while I'm at it
as councilor Reed comfortable and
continuing on that committee I do
understand that um there was a switch
between Richard and
um yourself you're happy to continue
thank you councilor Reed
the other one was just some
clarification on the waste net as you
will see
um I will be stepping away from that but
I do intend to continue to attend those
meetings in the interim until we get
this three bin system over the line but
me and Council Phillips have an
understanding there so just for
clarification
there aren't any further comments
um could I have a mover
that the council confirm the memberships
listed here with just that adjustment to
the chief vehicle appraisal committee
moved by Council Havel seconded by
councilor Stringer
all those in favor please say aye
and against motion is carried thank you
councilors
dangerous or and or incentury building
policy review did we have anything to
add to the report there Morgan
I think you Worship in through you a
very procedural report this one
um to jogs and memories though however
are on the 20th of June the policy
regulatory committee
the review of the dangerous Senate
Century buildings policy I found that it
was just a bit short in some of its
legislative requirements as such we've
had to review it but of course it's got
to be done through the postulates or
stipulations of the spiritual
consultation procedure is defined by
section 83 of the local government act
so essentially what this report is doing
is just to inform the councilors and of
course the community about the opening
of consultation on the policy
um
and it's all I have to add thank you
thank you Morgan do we have any
questions for Morgan on this report
do we have any discussion
Council
so we have another piece of government
legislation that requires changes to
buildings
and under all the district plans those
people if they're wanting to change
their building it's more than likely
they'll need a resource consent to do it
adding further costs to meeting the
government's regulations my question
is well I posted as a question really to
the chief executive as to whether
favorable consideration can be given to
the waving if not and full at least in
part of resource fees where upgrades are
required to buildings and necessitated
by this policy
foreign
that would require a specific resolution
of the council the council staff can't
act outside
its remit which is to treat every
applicant on a on a fair and consistent
basis a lot of councils do provide
incentives for owners of Heritage
buildings and that can be in the form of
subsidizing feasibility studies so sub
waving fees and those type of situations
would be would fall within that category
but it would need to come from the
council as a formal resolution so that
so the council staff can act on that but
in principle no no impediment whatsoever
I'm wondering
um
it's it's a bit hard to develop
something on the run with a policy like
this so if it's appropriate I'd like to
move that we actually receive a report
on the options available to the council
for the waving in part or in full where
a resource consent is required to meet
the obligations of this policy
foreign
ports or submissions received referred
to the policy and Regulatory committee
yes cool thank you counselor
do we have any further discussion
do we get that recommendation to this
could I please have a mover of those hit
of recommendations plus the one that
Council Hotel just moved moved by
Council of L
second ride counselor Reed
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
number nine page 43 future of combined
courts Association building do we have
anything further to add from Neil on
this report
through your worship
um I think we'll take their reporters
read
but the there's two considerations here
and one is that this particular building
has become available
um due to a financial hardship of the
club that has been looking after it for
the last number of years but this
situation has first arose a couple of
years ago but due to Grants they've
managed to keep going but um only with
the heat above water
but it does draw attention to a larger
implication of sports groups using
especially the green belt throughout
Gore so that is why there isn't another
recommendation
about looking forward and on that aspect
thank you now any questions for Neil on
this topic Council Havel and then
councilor Fraser
with with regard to the third
recommendation would setting up another
subcommittee duplicate the work that is
progressing from the group that is
looking at the review of the recreation
management plans
because I saw this issue was actually
Fallen within that group already
I was in to agree counselor that
probably will be covered in the reserve
management plan yeah I'm getting nods
from other Chief Executives there
councilor Fraser
that's where you you worship um just you
you you're saying that this is an up and
coming problem how many others are we
are you expecting or thinking you're
going to end up this way
uh the situation as it is is
sports groups are becoming often less
membership
and as I point out in there there's two
tennis clubs and three bowling clubs
within the green belt
um and I respectively disagree with
councilor Havel on that this necessarily
comes under the
reserve management plan that we're
looking at
that is to do with the management of the
actual Reserves
what we're talking about is a management
also
in combination of
hell the sports groups
react together and if need be do do they
have a um join
for the betterment of the sport but also
the betterment of the facilities in the
green belt
and I don't believe that's really
covered under the joint on the
management plan is such that we're
looking at
this is more to do with the actual
Sports
that recommendation
I think now did you enjoyment
thanks uh you worship I think there is a
I I can actually appreciate where um
Neil is coming from but there is a I
think there's an efficiency argument
here that you've got a the reserve
management plan subcommittee which is
definitely looking at each individual
Reserve its use and potential and future
Trends and then you've got a an Allied
issue here of
um potential sports clubs emerging
assets that need to be used
and that they're both in the
recreational space so in terms of
efficiency of
utilizing an existing subcommittee which
has already got its head into the
current and future trends of
recreational use on specific reserves it
would seem to me to be economical to
just assign this particular task to that
committee as well as opposed to doing
the local government special thing which
is creating a committee for every
non-course so I think that's probably
where I can see where it's coming from
um you know this is an issue that uh
going back to council Fraser's point
this is an issue that is grappling
um
communities around New Zealand both on
two fronts in my view one is that sports
clubs particularly in Gore they were set
up when Gore's population
projections were a lot more buoyant than
it is today and you can only likes to go
high school and its role you can see how
that has reduced from its Halcyon Days
of the 60s and 70s if they tell me 12
1300 kids now to half that number or
whatever the other thing to remember of
course is that Trends and Recreation
have changed a lot both in terms of
generational and personal taste so
there's been more a move away from
structured formal Recreation into
unstructured
and non-club aligned Recreation and
again one owners to look at say the
likes of Hamilton Park and how that use
has evolved in the last 10 years where
lots of people are down there they don't
belong to a club or organization they're
going down there to recreate they do it
in their own time frame and they do it
with a multiple array of pastimes that
they exercise and that's the the new way
of doing things and so that's where
traditional sports clubs struggle to
actually commandeer and recruit the next
wave of members because they're doing
something else
thank you Steve uh councilor McKenzie
we're just talking about the building at
Preston Street
other courts and everything all included
in that package the land that's there as
well
the actual land is all Reserve Land so
it all is all Council land yeah okay the
building was constructed by the war
tennis club and the gore netball
Association many years ago
thank you
thank you councilor councilor Dixon
thank you worship I'm just thinking
perhaps the reserve Management Group
could take special note of this
particular item and we could do a little
bit of research with these other clubs
as Neil has suggested because I think it
would be good to see where they're all
coming from and and what their basis is
to to continue
and their viability as well
we could just add that into our terms of
reference for this group
yeah thank you councilor I would I would
tend to agree I just I take note at the
chief executive comments around Trends
and do wonder if it
fits into the ltp process but it might
fit in as part of the reserve Reserve
management plan so I definitely agree
that I don't think we need a
subcommittee here but it does need to
fit in some way to have that focus on
moving forward
any further questions uh councilor
McDonnell
I think I've had a look at this building
walk around it the immediate problem is
the gutters then the sofites so I think
we have to put in the long-term plan a
budget of something like 30 grand
because you can have to scaffold that
building that's two stories higher
that's five grand before you start so
that's the sort of number I'd be
chucking at it to fix to fix the
immediate problems so
for Tech ownership or then we've got to
find the uh ultimately find a use for it
or a tenant in some form
and that could take many forms
so it could even be converted into
housing it's a substantial building
okay thank you thank you councilor I
think he took a question that I actually
had for Murray if he feels comfortable
of what
um was the estimated cost for the for
the immediate maintenance work and and
how immediate is it does it need to be
done as soon as we get the ownership of
it
the rough estimate because I haven't got
a quote as yet but the rough estimate
was about ten thousand
um just uh the what needs to be done
immediately as far as this
and also a bit of planking but the
you could say yes we can hold off to the
ltp
but just because the rain has not
entered the inside
yet does not mean to say it's going to
start any day
so I would be reluctant to hold off
until the ltp another
um
into the next financial year
yeah thanks there Neil I guess my line
of thinking was I'm cautious of pouring
really any money into it without having
that discussion of whether we whether
we're going to use it or completely
refit it or demolish or explore those
options but totally appreciate that it
is a it is a risk of the longer we wait
the more the more dangerous it could get
in deteriorating that building
do you want to go again sorry to your
worship uh the elected members need to
realize that if the club walks away from
it it is a problem
um it is on Reserve Land
the the building is in sound condition
except the guttering
um and so
in the long term it could be used by the
tennis club and possibly some other
clubs but it would cost
possibly half half the value to demolish
it anyway
but otherwise you've got a building for
the next so many years going forward and
hopefully if
there is discussion amongst the sports
groups and there was a merge between
tennis clubs that would be the audio
location for it
thank you for that clarity now do we
have any further questions uh Council
McDonough not a question I agree with
Neil it needs
fixed pretty much immediately the safety
are actually falling down so they've
lost their hold whatever was holding
them up there in the first place I can't
see any battens or anything left so
I think it does need immediate attention
if we take it over
[Music]
thank you councilor uh Council McKinsey
just a comment and a question well the
question first is it actually being used
much
at the moment
well not today obviously
oh I can't speak for the club that is
using it the tennis club how often they
are but they do have regular
competitions and
mainly school age tennis training and
that up there
because I'm thinking slightly you know
further down the track
we don't want it the building to turn
into a liability if we're going to end
up owning it
is it possible if it's not going to be
used can it be sold to the highest
bidder the whole lot I know it's a
reserve but hey
we need to cut back on spending money on
things when we don't want something
that's going to just end up sucking up
Dosh over the years
just a thought
did any staff want to come in on the
sale of it potential
through you worship it's not a building
that really can be really creative it's
concrete block so there it's it's
staying put so then you're asking
someone to buy a building on land that
is not you can nearly owned by the
purchaser so a person will need to own
the building
uh lease the land from the Council on
terms that would give them security
tenure
so I don't know whether you would be
inundated with people crashing your door
down to say I need that button but I
could be wrong but
it's and also the use would have to be
compatible with the reserve management
plan in terms of it has to be out would
have to be Allied to uh
something to do with Recreation
um
for example you couldn't I don't think
off top of it here to have a business
even if they had a resource consent
conducting something for profit out of
that building which is on recreational
land so
off the top of my head if it was a
relocatable you see I think you'd be
more inclined to say you can you could
sell it for relocation but to sell it as
is on site for a person that wanted to
use it
um
probably I think you'd be more likely to
get someone to lease the building for a
period that may well be possible
thank you Steve just a question that
sprung to mind as might be one for Lorne
but
um do we have to depreciate against this
asset moving forward if we accept it as
a gift
uh through your worship there'll be a
number of costs um coming up looking at
the report there's two options though we
either accept the gift of the building
or we're going to end up with any way of
looking at it if the tennis club can't
pay the least currently can't pay the
insurance
so what will come with the with the
building is yes it'll be depreciated it
will have insurance against it and
there'll be some potentially running
costs there is potential to have more
than one lessee in there so it could be
opened up for more opportunities so and
saying that without doing a proper
investigation into all the options
available
um you know there could be ways to
offset the costs by having more than one
user of the building you might have some
some other clubs or or people who need
meeting rooms that don't want to use
their Community rooms or things like
that so there are there are definitely
options available but it will come with
costs regardless
Thank you Lorne
do we have any further questions or
discussion
okay cancer got on
who who was responsible for maintaining
the courts in the service
that has been the council
the actual tennis
um
the tennis club put some money into
resurfacing but ongoing it's really a
cultural responsibility for the playing
Court
any further discussion
the sense I'm getting is that um
it's either way it's it's going to come
into to council ownership at the end of
the day uh and that there does need to
be some more investigative work by both
elected members and staff as to what the
long-term future for this building is
are we comfortable with that last
recommendation
um
changing it to something along the lines
of being included as part of the reserve
management plan working group
looking around and seeing nods
did you get that change Susan what do
you want me to craft something nope you
got it cool
in that case could I please have a mover
of all of those recommendations with the
amendment to that bottom one uh
councilman seconded by councilor
guardine
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you counselors
uh item 10 on page 46 is the Strategic
framework Vision Community outcomes
activities and groupings of the
activities for the
2024-2034 long term plan uh did Jason
have anything to add to this report
through your worship nothing really
further to add just that I'll take the
reporters read this is sort of the first
part of the
long-term plan jigsaw
the Strategic framework vision and
Community outcomes
see at the high level Direction and the
activities and groupings of activities
for the long term plan
uh set how
um how we manage those activities
through this process so a good one to
get out into
um
the public domain but the only thing to
acknowledge again with this is that it
stays draft until the
long-term plan is adopted in June next
year so it's subject to change along
those processes further information
comes to light or through the
consultation process with our
communities who might want to submit on
changes to that otherwise have your
technical questions
thank you Jason any questions for Jason
on this report
any discussion about the report in front
of us
no changes or discussion I guess just
the only Point uh from me on this is
somewhat of an apology to the community
that we don't have enough time to
consult on the community outcomes we
have to take that as councilors that
there just simply isn't enough time to
consult on these Community outcomes and
then do that consultation back and forth
so
there will be plenty of time to consult
on the long-term plan as a whole but to
keep it moving at PACE we do need to set
these and move them forward but we we do
hope that the community understands the
four pillars and the uh the outcomes
underneath them
with that being said could I have a
mover for the recommendations outlined
below uh Council Dixon seconded by
councilor Phillips
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
uh 11 on page 51 establishment of Maori
Ward and the hokanui runanga
relationship the development did uh no
getting a shaking uh
the report is pretty straightforward
for those who have read it do we did any
of the committee want to a working group
want to add any comment
nope I'd just like to highlight that um
and thank the balcony for
um
for meeting with us and working with us
going forward I really appreciate it
there's been some good open
communication at the moment and really
excited to see um
what we put together moving forward and
also their honesty councilor Val
you worship councilor Dixon over the
years has had some Import in terms of
ewe issues and working with the hokanui
runanga
so my my request and I guess I move it
uh is that yourself myself councilor
Paul mcphail and councilor Dixon
um be the four representatives of the
council
thank you councilor you beat me to it
um is there any any disagreement with
that
that's great so with that change which I
can see Susan writing that down
um could obviously have a mover of those
recommendations oh sorry cancel the
reading I'm happy to move the
recommendation but I'd like to have an
addition to um paragraph two please or a
slight change
um that it would be changed to the
council agree
no I'll start again following
consultation with an advice from hokanui
ranunga Representatives that Gore
District Council agree not to establish
a Maori award for the 2025 try in
elections
thank you
well stated counselor did we get that
change Susan fantastic
no disagreement I wouldn't imagine so
it's very well put uh are you happy to
move that set of recommendations Council
read
thank you counselor and a second uh
councilor Stringer
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
uh page 53.12 connected motorhaku Joint
Committee
uh would the chief executive or the
representative like to speak to this at
all
so councilor mcphail
we take it as read but um basically
we're working through
with a
we appointed three people there for the
just transition asteroid digestion
throughout the committee and we're
looking at hiring someone to actually
lead the project so we're just in that
process at the moment which goes out on
the 17th of September so if anybody's
got any questions about it um
let me know
thank you councilor I'm just gonna
double chip I'm pretty sure it wasn't
here yes
fantastic thank you um so that bottom
recommendation
um we would just put a line through it
because we have already accepted um
councilor Paul mcphail as the
representative
um as part of an earlier item but could
I please get a mover for the three we
had a comment counselor if I can just
ask the question please and I think
councilor beside me is bitching with her
finger as well
um
so we we the report is asking us to sign
off on the terms of reference and it
made reference to the section of the
schedule 7 Clause 30 and the Local
Government Act which is the first step
requires agreement between the three
councils to actually establish the group
and and do certain things as that
happened
because as part of the agreement before
you've got to have that agreement in
place before you can agree to the terms
of reference and that agreement needs to
set out the representation from each
Council on how the chair is going to be
elected Etc so just a procedure question
we think we have we'll get back to you
on that one counselor
there was agreement to set up the
transition body so my question is is the
agreement now to set up the one moving
forward
imagine that the transition body made
the decision to set up the hence the
creation of the transition body it would
make
yes we've then got a sign off on the
next step
yeah yeah good point
we will I think we'll get back on that
one and then we can put it in as a
recommendation if we need to next
councilman
that suffice
fantastic were you happy to move the
other three recommendations
thank you counselor and a secondary
councilor Paul mcphail
do we have any further discussion
it's just it's just noting uh the
appointments minutes and receiving the
report
any further discussion does not look
like it oh there's in favor please say
aye
and against the motion is carried
uh the annual report on dog control
policy and practices page 64.13 uh any
further comment from the trivia
I'd just like to take this opportunity
to worship to really applaud the council
staff that work in this area
it is sometimes incredibly challenging
uh was highly distressed owners
sometimes agitated and sometimes
dangerous for the staff and they do a
really really good job and during the
year we had some staff shortages and
some of the council staff who are in the
periphery of regulatory functions had to
literally roll their sleeves up and get
out there and be a dog control Animal
control officer for a period of time and
so I just in the public setting I think
while the reporters
yeah but very modestly but very
confidently prepared by Council
regulatory staff they need to be
recognized for what has been a tough
year with some incredibly stressful
incidents that we've had to deal with
and they have done it with a plum and we
certainly look forward to the opening of
our new dog pound which will be a step
change in the service that we provide
for the dog owner community
thank you
thank you for that Steve any questions
for the chief executive
any discussion
I will ask for a mover
that the dog will be adopted
oh you had a question
just a comment I'd like to support
um what the chief executive was saying
because I experienced a dog owner at the
counter talking to staff
um and and I have to say that it was
admirable the way the staff handled this
person because they were very angry and
it was quite upsetting so I think staff
are doing a fantastic job and that
in that degree
thank you councilor would you like to
move that motion
and could I get a seconder uh councilor
Fraser
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
page 70.14 minutes of the waste net
meeting
would the chair of wasting it like to
comment at all
thank you you worship the the minutes
that are there are in really a summary
form and I just wanted to highlight that
I've been questioned on several accounts
in terms of when are we going to move
forward with recycling here at Gore and
it's the strong wish of everyone around
the table that we do proceed as soon as
practicable
um but at the same time we need to be
mindful of doing it in the most cost
effective way
there are moves across the the region
particularly and invercargill for health
and safety reasons for keeping glass and
other recycling materials separate
um and so we're having a full recycling
system here in Gore it needs to be for
health and safety reasons um three three
bin system so an additional bin that
represents a change in the level of
service we're offering and hence we need
to consult on that and from a cost point
of view we're looking at I guess two
sources of cost saving
um one is moving together with
invercargill so that we have some
economies of scale in terms of
purchasing new Bins
invercargill is
the timing of when they go to
consultation therefore we probably if
there is no I'll go back a step we we
could go by ourselves and we need to
know what the difference is between us
going by ourselves and actually joining
with invercargill and going with them if
it is worthwhile from an economy of
scale to work together with invercargill
then the timing of invercargill city in
terms of Consulting will need to fit
them with as well and hopefully we'll
get an indication from the city in the
near future as as to their timing
secondly waste net last year made a
surplus of just on five hundred and
forty thousand dollars
um and
um I would be hopeful that waste net may
be in a position to offer a subsidy to
the councils to help reduce the cost so
we need to work through those issues
um prior to Consulting with the public
if we were to order the bins now I'm
told it could take 10 months before the
bins arrive and we can actually get the
system up and running so we're probably
not going to meet the one July date of
next year that we're really trying our
best to get there but we need to be
mindful of the costs that are involved
in the processes that we've got to go
through I don't know if the general
manager of critical Services wants to
comment further or ADD
foreign
and again it has been significant
progress of late
um I think there's certainly that desire
there regionally in the space um but
this is not I guess news to us that we
we've sort of been communicating for
since we started looking at this last
year around that sort of delay or lag
time from when we make a decision to
then getting bins landed and distributed
so we obviously want to move that as
fast as we can and we are doing so but
it comes down to trying to balance that
with the potential cost savings for our
community so that's still that
um piece that we're having to work
through but there's some some good
alignment there
um regionally that hopefully can benefit
the gore rope has
thank you Jason and counselor uh do we
have any questions from councilors
uh councilor Phillips thank you just a
reminder that it is actually the three
councils
SDC ICC and GDC
thank you councilor
uh councilor mcfarrell uh three just
just a question of watching through from
the outside is it fair to say that all
three councils are working in the same
direction
waste Neti has been particularly active
this year at a governance level and
um
we we are working together in unison
um on on some key things that in
previous years may not have been as
um uh productive as it is now
um so I'm hopeful that the initiatives
that we're now putting in place uh going
to see both
um the way wasting it operates
regionally
um as well as the impact it has on the
individual councils is being a step up
and I made and councilor Phillips is
correct Southland is also part of it the
urban areas are probably the easiest to
supply the bins to Southland has some
particular issues that it needs to
address and it may well be because of
the size of Southland and the distances
between towns that they need to adopt a
slightly different approach but we're
working through that
thanks for that I'd just like to commend
the work you are doing because it's a
difficult scenario really working with
all the different councils so keep up
the good work thank you
thank you councilor and just to shed
some more light to your point there
um councilman Fowler I think it all
counts also heading in the same
direction but there might be some
discrepancies around timing um and
that's what we're trying to figure out
um and and lucky for our district we are
wanting to go earlier than others
um given the position we're in so I'm
hopeful that all works out but
ultimately it might be cost effect us
most cost effectives go at the same time
any further questions comments
could have a move that the report is
received
councilman McKenzie seconded by
councilor McDonnell
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
page 78 now the minutes of the matoda
community board meeting
did the war counselor like to speak to
this at all
um just take them as read the worship
without having to answer any questions
anything councilors may wish to
um bring forward to me
just that um as you can see there's only
a couple of items there but there is
some
uh good things happening down in matara
hoping the signs will be ready shortly
I said I don't say that in jespa I'm
just hoping but um
uh we are holding a workshop on the 21st
of this month
um
with uh I think is about 27 different
items on the list of
wishes and things for the for the
10-year plan so we're going to work
through those and put our priorities
through and yeah so things are looking
really good
it sounds great counselor councilor
Stringer and then cancel read you know
three worship them to um
Council Phillips
um have the bases on that being put on
the for the signs so everything is ready
to go they can just be dropped in
instead of the signs turn up and we wait
around for another month where we get
bases in that built
not at the stages when I passed on today
though it was still the old signs that
were pulled down in a few flares on
there that's about it
councilor Reed
yeah
um I'd just like to make comments on the
business of the waimumu stream planting
and acknowledge the work of the Parks
and Recreation manager that he's gone to
to Source planter plants
um and just also acknowledge the
generosity of the renango for providing
2 000 plants for the Waterway it's
a good a good Community effort
thank you counselor
any further comments
could I have a move that those minutes
are received
councilor Reed and a seconder councilor
Phillips I will put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
and against
the motion is carried
uh summary of the mural form for a
meeting
there's a pretty brief summary there
um
nothing more to add for myself
do we have any questions
sorry you worship but on the previous
item
um
you you've only got emotion in terms
that they be received there was a second
one that said the recommendations
contained in the minutes be ratified
does that need to be explicitly passed
as well
apologies I didn't read that one out as
there isn't anything specific there
needs to be ratified it's just all
receiving information in there
any questions on Merrell forum
could I please have a mover that those
minutes are received
councilor MacDonald secondary councilor
Fraser I will put the motional who's in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried we're
gonna have a brief break before we go
into committee
um as uh Jason wants to shoot some
information with with councilors um